Hello, welcome to LED Live, where today
we're going to discuss AI.
What is this thing? Should we use it?
Should we not? Is it good for us? Is it
bad for us? I'm sure you've got a lot of
questions, and we have a special guest,
Harvey, Dr. Harvey Alvarez. Awesome to
have a doctor in the house, and you have
a lot of expertise in this area, so I'm
very excited about this conversation,
because I have questions, and I want to
know some things about this, so Thank
you for your invitation. It is great to
be here. Yeah. Love it. Harvey, tell us
a little bit about you're a professor.
You teach at a college. Yes, at Southern
Adventist University here in Tennessee.
Cool. And I teach at the School of
Computing.
I teach courses related to artificial
intelligence, big data, data science. Um
yeah, especially at the master's level.
Okay. So, you got you got you got all
the brains in the in that department,
I'm sure. Yes, yes, my students are
brilliant, and we are doing research, we
are doing projects in this area, so
praise the Lord. Awesome. Well, we have
a lot of questions um coming up in this
area over the years, and um you know, we
use we use AI. I think everybody kind of
sort of uses AI, right? You got one of
these things, you're using it pretty
much.
AI. Siri is AI, right? You got an Alexa
at home or something like that, you got
AI. Um so, you know, some of the
questions that come into our ministry,
where do we draw the line? You know,
what is this What is this thing, and how
should we respond to it, and you know,
is this thing driving us towards some
crazy end? Yeah.
So, artificial intelligence is not
something new.
It was formally established in the
1950s.
Um by a group of professors in computer
science. They said, "Okay, let's define
this new area
uh related to how to make computers
to think, you know, to think as humans."
Mhm. So, they were quite
um positive at that time. They thought
that maybe in a
in a matter of
5 years or 10 years, they will achieve
general artificial intelligence, or
artificial intelligence that has the
same level of intelligence of humans,
but they didn't achieve that. We haven't
achieved that. Reminds me of I, Robot
with Will Smith. Yeah, yeah. You seen
that movie?
We are on the eve of the largest robotic
distribution in history. By Saturday,
there'll be one robot to every five
humans. Woah. Yeah, so we haven't
achieved that yet. When was the first
computer made?
Wow.
That is a great question.
Um
a computer is a machine that makes
calculations, so
uh there are examples, very old examples
of that.
Um the difference with artificial
intelligence,
you know, compared to computers that
already existed at that time,
Mhm. was to create a machines that could
learn from data. Okay. So,
traditionally,
um
you know, you create algorithms, Mhm. uh
which are very deterministic. So, you
say, "Okay, for these particular
actuators, you get these actions, or you
get these responses."
Um but the idea with artificial
intelligence, as and especially with
something called machine learning,
is about giving the computer data,
uh sample data, let's say images or
text, and then the computer can learn
from this data. Mhm. Yeah, that is the
big biggest difference from what other
people had done, you know, from several
years back, you know, in computer
science. Mhm. Uh and now with uh from
the '50s, using machine learning,
especially. I saw this video one time
where this really deep learning, where
they um had a little stick figure, and
they wanted him to um learn how to run.
They gave him no instructions
whatsoever, and he taught himself how to
run, and then they would put objects in
front of him, and he would stumble over
them, but then he really quickly
learned, "Oh, I need to jump over that
thing, or climb over it, or avoid it
altogether." And the thing literally
taught itself to run, jump, avoid
objects, and they didn't teach it
anything.
Yes, that that's the idea. That's the
idea, and especially nowadays,
uh this is this has become so important.
For example, with autonomous vehicles,
how many rules, deterministic rules, do
you need, you know, to
to create an autonomous car? You know,
thousands, millions. And in fact,
artificial intelligence, you know, when
it was formally established in the '50s,
that was the idea, to create
a a set of rules Mhm. uh to tell a
computer, "Do this or do that." Mhm. You
know,
when when the computer finds a
particular situation, does this. Mhm.
But how many options or rules Mhm. you
you have to create, you know, in the
open world? For example, with autonomous
cars, that is impossible. Okay, here we
go.
Says your car is on the way in 4
minutes. Oh, there it is. Oh, but it
stopped. I'm here. Oh, I think it's
confused.
Better run before
it goes away. It wasn't supposed to stop
here.
Okay.
We're going to pick my son up at the
Randall Museum.
I thought it was going to feel like
unsafe, because, you know, my life is in
this car's hand, the computer.
But actually, I feel like really
chillax.
So, what I do like is that it's
following the speed limit, so it's very
safe.
Um and when it comes to a stop, it does
a complete stop, not like a California
stop, like we all do.
Now, like everything, it's something
new.
Okay, I think we're stopped. Oh my god.
Yes. Okay.
All right, right now, there's a green
light,
and nothing is happening.
We are stuck. And not only that, we're
not even on the left-hand side properly.
Uh-oh.
Okay, it says our team is working to get
you moving. Uh-oh.
It was green light, it didn't know what
to do. So, how can I rely on a car to
make the right decisions, when it can't
read a simple green light? Now, we're
going. Here we go.
Woah.
For your safety, the doors will remain
locked when we arrive. So, I guess it's
a little confused, because this is not
where the Randall Museum is.
So, I don't know what to do at the
moment. If had there been a driver right
here, I would have said, "Hey, you know,
you This is the wrong location." And I
would give him the instructions, except
that there's instructions, there's
nobody here right now.
Now, I'm going to have to call support,
and see what I could do, cuz I'm
completely at a loss right now.
Um the location where I want to be is
over there, and it's dropped me at the
bottom of this hill.
I wish I could talk to the driver.
Then tell him, "Make a right, make a
left."
Wait a minute, wait a minute. It's Oh,
it's going to make right again.
Oh, wait wait, it might Oh, it's
dropping me in the same place where it
dropped me off before. Okay, we're back
to square one.
Hello, Max.
Vehicle approaching. Sorry, sorry it
didn't work out.
Then I felt like trapped inside here. I
just felt like so
useless in this.
You don't hire a driverless car, it
drops you off, and then tells you, "Your
location is
uh
5 minutes away walking." That's that's
not even cool. My son could have ran, or
you know, walked down the hill. That
would have been okay. But what if it had
been a disabled person, somebody on
crutches, in a wheelchair? Um they can't
do that.
I came into this like with a lot of
optimism, and now I'm not sure. I would
say, "Have fun with it, but be prepared
to be frustrated."
That's why
uh the the the the the area of
artificial intelligence has changed from
rule-based
to something more flexible, you know?
So, for example, now we talk about
ChatGPT. Mhm. So, with ChatGPT, we have
a lot of data
from the web that was used to train
these models, and these models learn
from data. Mhm. The trick behind
ChatGPT is that in addition of having
this big amount of data, they also have
these powerful machines from Microsoft,
you know, to train these models, because
it takes a lot of computer power to
train that. For simple models, you can
use your machine, it's fine. It can take
some hours or days to train a model, but
for something bigger, you need a lot of
money. Yeah. to do that. Those
underground cities that you've only
heard about, that probably nobody's ever
visited. Yes.
Those kind of things. Yes, of course.
Yeah, you know, these
data centers that consume a lot of
energy to do these kind of things. Mhm.
So, the large language models that that
a lot of this is built on,
are they better with some languages than
others? So, for example,
we know they're trained on English, but
what about other foreign languages? Are
they as good? Are they better? Are they
the same?
That's a good question. Um in the past,
for example, talking about ChatGPT,
uh there was a gap between English and
other languages.
English
The results in English were better,
but with the new version of ChatGPT or
GPT version 4.0,
the the gap has reduced a lot. So, we
can find also very good results in other
languages. But, of course, there are
there are still gaps, you know? For
example, and this is not something new,
you know? Some years ago, I used to live
in Thailand
and languages from that area of the
world
are not so well
used, you know, to train or to Even at
that time, it was almost 20 years ago,
how to internationalize,
you know,
a user interface, you know, according to
those languages, it was a challenge
because there was not support.
And we still have challenges with some
particular languages such as Khmer, you
know, from Cambodia and this kind of of
languages.
You you would think that like every
single
discipline in life would use this.
You know what I mean? Like Like if you
had things I mean, I just think of like
the military's
use for it, right? We fly people in
planes and and and and very dangerous
situations that you're putting them in.
Well well, can't you train the computer
to like get up there in that machine and
like, you know, see where all the
missiles are and drop this over here and
do this over there? I mean, it's like
that just could go into, you know, the
military and, you know, what about
education? You have this machine now
that's got this crazy amount of
information pool.
How's How's that going to affect your
job? It will affect a lot of jobs.
Especially repetitive jobs.
Let's say my wife is an accountant, for
example, and I usually tell her, you
know, what will happen in the future,
you know, in your profession, with your
profession? Because so many things in
accounting are are very repetitive
and systematic.
Things are going to change.
And we have to be careful. Yeah? Because
we are think we have to think about
people, you know, real people. So, what
will happen with these people who are
currently doing something,
but maybe in 5 years
they can be replaced by machines. So,
well, I think it's going to be like
Wall-E.
Watch
over here.
Whoa.
Hey, drink the punch.
Here, take the cup. Hey, take the cup.
Whoa.
Please remain stationary. A service bot
will be here to assist you momentarily.
Stewards,
hello. Please remain stationary. A
service bot will be here to assist you
momentarily.
What's that? What's going on?
We're all just going to get like chubby.
That's We're all going to just drive
around in these automatic chairs with
screens in front of our faces. If you
want to know why Wall-E's bad,
check out her video. Yeah, so even the
the technology technological gap is big
nowadays.
If you see places such as Africa,
people in in places there do not know
how to use PowerPoint, for example, or
Microsoft Word.
So, now with artificial intelligence, if
they don't know how to use it, if they
don't have the infrastructure to train
their models,
if they don't have the data, so the gap
is going to become bigger and bigger.
So, as you can see here, we live in the
fourth industrial revolution now.
Although computers are important,
now we are moving into something related
to artificial intelligence, big data,
because we need a lot of data to train
this artificial intelligence and
robotics. Maybe you have seen the latest
videos from Boston Dynamics, you know,
their new robots, humanoids. You know,
this is amazing, you know, like
they do these
acrobatic things and so on. So, it's
big.
So, you can see that even at this point
of time, there are countries, people who
are in this third industrial revolution.
They haven't moved from computers into
this. So, the gap can become even bigger
and bigger. I can't wait to the little
arm that cooks for you, you know, it's
just on a little track. And then you can
just literally order from your phone
what you want and you come home and it
goes over your fridge, opens up your
stuff, and cooks everything that you
want, and will literally put it on the
table for the time that you get home.
That'll be crazy.
But then
yeah, look at how that depersonalizes
the object of cooking with your mate and
together and it's a family orient, you
know, deal where you're kind of working
for your food. It's just going to
cheapen food, I think. Yes. So,
I can say that although there are
challenges with artificial intelligence,
we can also use artificial intelligence
for good. We have to be balanced in this
point of view, and I will show you now
some examples of research projects I
have done with my students. So, for
example, in this research project,
we published a paper with the results on
the detection of melanoma, which is a
skin cancer, using image recognition. It
was several years ago, you see, in the
2015,
we were working on artificial
intelligence. So, this is not something
new. Yeah? And it can be useful, for
example, in remote areas where you don't
have an specialist, you know,
dermatologist. So, you can use these
kind of approaches to detect cancer. And
we have also used it to detect glaucoma,
which is a very common disease, eye
disease. So, I got a question for you.
Can you take a photo of your
basically your mole and just upload it?
Yes, so you upload you take a picture
and then
the model detects if there is evidence
or not of melanoma according to this
percentage of detection. So, in this
case, we use something called a vanilla
artificial
neural network,
a classical neural network.
In recent approaches, we have used
more recent topologies or architectures
of deep learning.
For example, in this case, we use
inception, for example. This is a
convolutional neural network
to detect glaucoma. Okay, so
you can detect if a patient has
glaucoma. These are images of glaucoma
and these are non-glaucomatous
eyes. So, the idea is not to replace the
medical doctor, but
to help the doctor have a better
diagnosis because there is evidence of a
lot of misdiagnosis
in the world.
So, we have to be careful with that and
that's why we work on this.
We also published a paper on the
detection of difficult airway using deep
learning. Deep learning is the idea of
having very deep neural artificial
neural networks.
So, we try to imitate our topology, the
way our
neurons are connected to each other.
So, the idea is that we have a visual
cortex. So, we have different layers
from the first layer up to the back.
And then
in each layer, there are operations that
happen. So, we try to imitate these
operations using mathematics. Okay,
convolutions, max pooling, and other
other operations there. So, in this
case, what we tried to do
was to prevent people from dying
during a surgery.
So, you know that some people,
you know, they come to the surgery and
they are intubated,
but they according to their morphology,
they should not be intubated.
So, what we did was to train this model
with a lot of pictures
from students. So, we asked these
students,
"Please open your mouth." So, we took
this picture. "Open your mouth."
Picture, picture, picture. Then an
specialist an anesthesiologist
took these images and manually
classified them. So, there are four
levels of
classification, Mallampati, with the
Mallampati score. So, he said, "Okay,
these images are of Mallampati one,
Mallampati two, Mallampati three." So,
you can see, for example, in this case,
these people should not be intubated
because you don't have enough space
here.
You see?
In this case, this person can be
intubated because they have enough space
here.
So, the idea is to support
the work of medical doctors.
In this other example,
we used
several images
of blueberries. We work I work with one
of my students who come from the country
of Chile.
They had there this a smart farm.
They created this robotic arm, and here
you have these trays of blueberry
plants. So, and here you have a camera,
okay? So, the camera takes pictures of
the situations that are happening here
in these trays and according to this
information, it recognizes uh for
example, if some plants are dying or if
this and it's that.
Yeah, so is this the same technology
like when you have an app that takes a
picture of a of a of a plant and it can
tell you what you need to do to fix the
plant?
So,
um
you can see that the idea behind these
projects and the idea behind artificial
intelligence nowadays is to have enough
data. I will not say big data.
I will say good data. So, you have good
data, good images to train these models,
it will work. Hopefully, it will work.
The problem is most of the world is not
good. Yes. And that's the point, for
example, with ChatGPT, you know?
They they have taken image Oh, sorry,
text. Okay, now the latest model also
uses images, you know, and video and so
on. But let's talk about text. So, if
you take
data from the web, what about the
quality of this data?
Is it going to be good or not? So,
Wikipedia, you never know what you get.
So, garbage in, garbage out. And that is
a a very delicate situation
because
if people are making decisions,
you know, depending on these tools,
according to the output from these
tools,
and if the data that has been used to
train these models is
is like a black box, you don't know
where it came from. So, That's a really
good point. I I remember, I think it was
Mikey, who's part of our team, who used
ChatGPT to ask a specific Bible question
and it looked at some of the data that's
found online and it was completely off.
But somebody might use that and ask the
same question and be like, "Oh, see, you
know, that's that's how it is." Just
like people treat Wikipedia. They think
that Wikipedia is a is a reliable
source, but it's just humans who just
type in their own thoughts and and it's
considered as as a reliable source. I
was in journalism school a couple years
ago and um
yeah, we were taught you cannot use
Wikipedia as a source, period. And I bet
you they'd say the same thing now about
ChatGPT for that reason. Yeah, and
that's a great point. And these kind of
models, especially when we talk about
large language model, in fact, GPT is a
large language language model. ChatGPT
is one of many large language models. It
is the most famous because, you know,
Microsoft is behind that. There is so
much money behind that. But there are so
many others. Okay. So,
what I was going to say is that these
models have hallucinations,
you know? When you read the text, the
output, it looks very convincing.
But
as as you mentioned, you know, it just
changes the sense, you know, the the the
the the the the truth. Yeah, yeah. You
don't know what kind of thing bent it's
like, you know, answer or whatever.
Exactly.
Very interesting.
Exactly. So, so I think, you know,
looking at this image, if we were to
keep going forward, we'd probably end up
like at the end of the matrix, you know,
with this
machine that's planting everything.
But I do think this is brilliant. I
mean, think of the the the the thing
that this could help out if if hunger is
a big thing in the world and, you know,
this is something that can really ensure
that those plants are growing and
everything. I mean, I I see that as
positive. You know, speaking of good AI,
I like listening to scripture songs made
with AI. I think it's awesome, you know,
like uh I think it's called Suno. That's
a website that's out there. We use Suno
to make Christian kids content
sometimes, kids songs. But I mean, it's
a great way to memorize scripture. And
by the way, if you want to memorize
Bible songs, go to I think the YouTube
channel is called @BibleScriptureSongs.
We'll have a pop-up right here and you
can do it for yourself. You can listen
to them and memorize scriptures at
Scripture Songs. And subscribe to that
because, you know, there's new ones
being put on there and you you you know,
if you want to learn a new scripture,
great place to do it.
It's awesome. Okay, so here I have some
more examples. Um in this project, we
work with a student with a one of my
students and two professors from the
University of Loma Linda, Loma Linda
University. And
uh we use this to automatically classify
uh plutonic rocks. So, if you're a
student, a geology student, you don't
know how so much, you know, about how to
classify particular rocks, so you're in
the field, you take the sample and then
the model can tell you, you know, this
belongs to this class or that class. So,
we also used
uh images, you know, to train this
model. We also
um used uh artificial intelligence.
Uh in this case,
we use it for something called a
sentiment analysis.
So, how to recognize the needs of people
in big places or in a neighborhood? Are
you going to go to every house, you
know,
knock to the door, you know, and
"Can you please tell me your needs?" No,
it's so time-consuming and, you know?
So, what I did in this project was to
take tweets from Twitter or X. Um and
then I applied a sentiment analysis,
which is about
automatically recognizing
which tweets are positive and which are
negative related to different topics,
you know, family or food, vegetarian
food, um
and different topics like dirty topics.
And here, for example, in this case, you
can see the most negative areas in New
York City, you know, at the end, the
focus was on on Manhattan because most
of the tweets were
at that time were tweeted from there.
And you can see this, you know, in red.
So, the idea with data science, we can
say that data science is about the
application of science to discover
patterns, hidden patterns from data,
okay? So, one of the tools that we can
use is machine learning or artificial
intelligence, yeah, to recognize these
these patterns.
So, and data science is actionable. So,
which actions are you going to take if
you know that people here tend to be
negative? So, you have churches or
schools, you know, in this area and if
you know the particular needs of people
in these areas, you can take proactive
actions.
Mhm. Or you can
know the needs of your audience
beforehand, you know?
And in even even, you know,
now I remember a project I did with one
of my students several years ago.
It was about discovering the emotions of
people as they watch particular videos.
So, that approach
is also used by ESPN to realize when
people are so attracted to a game, so
they can launch, you know, a particular
ad.
So, uh we use artificial intelligence to
do that and it works. It works. Uh to
realize when people are sad or bored.
So, the webcam was recognizing, you
know, the
you know, the face of the person in real
time and we could realize in which
particular point people tend to be
bored, you know? So, these are the kind
of things we can do. So, the examples
that I have shown you so far are in the
area of weak AI.
Why weak? Because they are focused on
particular areas of knowledge.
Let's say you create a model to play
chess
and that model is good for chess only,
only for chess, not for more, okay? So,
this is weak AI and we are at at this
point now, okay?
But the expectation of several people,
industry, scientists,
uh is to move into something called a
strong AI or artificial artificial
general intelligence, which is about
creating uh
these
um artificial brains that
are useful to solve different problems.
Just one model solving different
problems.
Like a murder or something. Yeah. So,
you can have a model to play chess and
the same model will drive a car and the
same model will do everything.
So, not just not just good at that one
task. I see what you're saying. Yeah.
Like a human being, like a human being.
Yeah. So,
some people,
there are books about this, there are
experts
who defend this point of view, who say
that when we achieve this point of
artificial general intelligence, we will
come into something called the
technological singularity,
okay? Which is an explosion of
intelligence that we cannot even
imagine.
So,
it will be a time of humans version 2.0.
It will be a time in which machines will
surpass our level of intelligence or
even a time in which we will see a
combination of human brain together with
artificial intelligence to go farther,
you know, to be more intelligent, more
intelligent, more capable and even to
reach eternal life.
So,
I will focus um
in the following slides on this area,
the singularity. Because I think that
it has very
delicate philosophical
dimensions. Well, well, it's like, you
know,
I'm I'm I'm just seeing things from like
the Bible, right? Like like like what
was offered to Adam and Eve when when
the whole snake came and you're going to
have knowledge and you're going to have,
you know, eternal life and you're going
to have all these things. It's like it's
interesting to me that this is where
this is kind of like going to.
Let's see. Yeah. Yes, Scotty. Yeah,
let's see.
So, as you can see,
audience, as you can see,
artificial intelligence is great.
Artificial intelligence is great. We can
do it we can use it for good.
We should use it for good. But
the
there are negative implications that
happen when we take it as a religion,
you know, at a spiritual level. And I
will focus on this in the following
slides. So, here you can see
in this figure that human intellect is
growing, okay, according to time and
intellectual level power, okay? So, more
human intellect. But according to the
idea of the singularity or the
technological singularity, there is a
point here
in which
machine intelligence surpasses
human intelligence in something called
transhumans.
Transhumans, okay? So, this is
important. The singularity is this
point. So, ChatGPT is not considered
transhuman yet, right? It's like it's
basically like the example I gave
earlier of I, Robot where they are
actual human beings that can technically
take over the world. That's kind of what
transhuman is.
Transhuman transhumanism
sounds very positive.
You know, at the first sight
is very positive and beautiful, you
know? The idea is to create better
humans who live longer, healthier,
happier, you know?
But
it has also implications related to
eternity. How to avoid death by our own
means.
And then in the following slides I will
show you the implications the biblical
implications that it has. Yeah. I'm
curious. Transhuman, I've heard it
described as transcending your human
entity with technology. Yeah. So. This
really reminds me of what they were
trying to do with the Tower of Babel.
You know? Yeah, I have exactly I have
even a
slide. Yes, yes. This
and that's why I think you you you
brought up earlier it's not a new
concept. I mean, I think I think this is
just probably circled around in previous
cultures. Yes, and in fact, here
I have this this image, you know, the
Ubermensch, you know, from Friedrich
Nietzsche. This idea of the Superman,
the superhuman. This is not something
new, you see? Adolf Hitler. Yes. That's
what he wanted. Yes, exactly. So,
answering your question, so
transhumanism is a philosophical and
scientific movement. Scientific because
it combines areas of artificial
intelligence, nanotechnology, genetic
engineering, which are important, you
know, scientific trends. So, the idea is
to combine all these to augment human
capabilities to live longer and
healthier and so on and to improve human
condition. Okay?
So,
there are different ideas of the future
of transhumanism. And in fact, there are
churches in California, for example,
of transhumanists. You know, they go and
they worship and all that. Worship
technology? Yes, correct. Yeah, you can
you can look online, you know, for on
YouTube, you know, about these churches.
And they attend these churches to
worship this kind of
No, it's something else.
Yeah, but I may say I haven't done
research on that area, but
maybe there are some common points or
common
They'll be the first ones to put the
Neuralink in. I'm sure they're going to
be like first adopters. common points,
yeah, relationships. So, transhumans
are expected to come as a combination of
human and artificial intelligence. That
is one idea of how it will become a
reality.
Another idea is to have this loaded
conscience, consciousness, and memories
to machines. So, in other words, you
have a thumb drive and you connect it to
your brain and then you get all these
memories and conscious consciousness and
then you put it into a machine and then
you will live forever. Not with this
body.
This body will die, but your thinking,
yeah, will live
for a long time or forever.
Another another way of thinking
transhumanism is to have fully synthetic
artificial intelligence. So, right now
there is no that consensus about how
transhumanism will
will be
materialized. But these are ideas about
how it will become. Yeah. And and I
think, you know, there's a lot of movies
that have been made about it. There is
certainly a lot of artists. You heard of
Black Eyed Peas? Yeah.
Their whole album and why they do the
automotive like robotic stuff like this.
They're totally into this. So, they're
singing about it. And it's like almost
like the art world is sort of preparing
the minds to accept this kind of stuff.
But I mean, Google Google these guys are
all they're all part of this. So, I
mean, they're going to push this huge
and these are the brightest minds, you
know? Yes, yes, Scotty, you are right.
So, one of the
big figures, you know, authors in the
area of transhumanism is Ray Kurzweil.
Okay, Ray Ray Kurzweil, he he's a
genius. He used to work at Google.
He's an inventor. He has received
prizes. He has published a lot of
bestseller books. So, in one of his of
his publications, he chose the different
epochs of evolution.
Six epochs of evolution, okay? So, it
starts with this evolution at the
physics and chemistry level, then it
moves into DNA, then into brains,
technology, merging of technology and
human intelligence, and then finally the
universe wakes up. So, here basically he
mentions that at this point when when
the merging comes, we will see the
explosion of intelligence, the
singularity, okay? And at the end it is
important to read this again, the
universe wakes up.
So, this is a
new era new age
wording, okay? The new universe of
happiness will happen when we combine
ourselves with technology into something
much better. So, as you mentioned, you
know, these are the ideas are not new.
I just mentioned Friedrich Nietzsche.
But here we also have Pierre Teilhard de
Chardin.
He was a French Jesuit Catholic priest.
He he's quite famous.
And he talks about something called the
Omega Point. Omega Point is a theorized
future event in which the entirety of
the universe spirals towards a final
point of unification. Wow.
And that's that's literally Bible
prophecy fulfilled if you read
Revelation and it comes from a French
Jesuit Catholic priest.
That's interesting. You know what I
mean? It's like you see these things in
our world today and it's like they
there's a plan. There is an agenda. So,
you can see that something so good as
artificial intelligence, in fact,
I'm a firm believer that God has given
us technology to do great things. I
think in heaven we'll invent stuff that
will continue to help, you know? Yes,
Scotty. But you see when when people
take these ideas
to defend their world views, you know, a
world view is like this pair of glasses,
you know, through which you filter
reality,
it becomes
dangerous
and strange sometimes. So, even, you
know, in this book, The Physics of
Immortality by Tipler, so
he has taken these ideas from
Teilhard de Chardin and he says this,
for example, evolution is converging
towards toward a final unity to present
a concept of God as a cosmic
computerized intelligence
that is equivalent to the Omega. The
Omega Point, you know, this point of
unification or as
Kurzweil said, this universe when the
universe wakes up.
He also says that when the Omega Point
is reached, everyone will experience a
computational resurrection into
immortality. I mean, you used a really
interesting word there cuz that's
exactly what I was thinking when you
said the universe wakes up. It's like
it's a counterfeit. We are going to wake
up and we are going to like, you know,
be unified with Jesus once again and for
never to be apart. Like when he prayed,
God, let me have these ones that I may
be with them and they with me. Yes, yes,
Scotty. I have here a couple of quotes
from, for example, Stephen Hawking in
one of the his interviews in The
Guardian. The primitive forms of
artificial intelligence we already have
have proved very useful, but I think the
development of full artificial
intelligence could expel the end of the
human race. So, you can see that there
are some
thinkers, you know, with this positive
point of view about the future, some
others who, in this case, you know, tend
to be more negative. But even Elon Musk,
I think we should be very careful about
artificial intelligence. If I had to
guess at what our biggest existential
threat is, it is probably that. So, we
need to be very careful. Yeah, he's one
of the biggest users. Yeah, and he
mentioned this in 2014. I I I wonder if
he realizes like, you know, you tell the
kid don't touch the button and they're
going to touch it. You know what I mean?
Like, if he comes out publicly and he's
like, "Yeah, don't use this." It's going
to fuel curiosity. I don't know. They
have a huge supercomputer
at Tesla. Massive. That's analyzing all
this
self-driving capability. I mean, the
thing is
I mean, it there's very few computers
that are probably like it in the world.
Do you think that the computer designed
Tesla?
That the computer designed Tesla?
Yeah. Can it design Tesla?
did. I don't think it did. I wonder if
they used artificial intelligence to
really I mean, it's a good it's a good
product, you know.
Yeah, it's possible. Um yeah, yeah, I
You would think if they had designed it,
they would have made the self-driving
better.
Nobody You still don't trust it?
So,
so here we have some questions. Will
technology change what it means to be
human?
With transhumanism or will artificial
intelligence make humans obsolete?
So, here I have some biblical
implications of the singularity that uh
we're going to discuss, you know, at
this point. So, the first implication is
that singularity the singularity is an
attempt to reach immortality through
machines.
Uh take a look at this quote from uh
this professor
I.J. Good, uh a famous professor in
computer science.
Uh this is old, 1965. Wow.
So, let an ultra-intelligent machine be
defined as a machine that can far
surpass all the intellectual activities
of any man, however clever clever. So,
it is about general artificial
intelligence or a strong artificial
intelligence. Since the design of
machines is one of these intellectual
activities, an ultra-intelligent machine
could design even better machines. As
you were talking about Tesla, you know,
like machines creating better machines.
There could then unquestionably be an
intelligence explosion.
The singularity.
And the intelligence of man could be far
left far behind.
Thus, the first ultra-intelligent
machine is the last invention that man
need ever make. And when it comes to
theology, it's a fascinating
it's a fascinating question, fascinating
thought because in
Ecclesiastes, it tells us
that God put eternity in our heart.
So, we have this recognition that
we know we're supposed to live forever.
But God put safeguards in place for that
because of sin.
It says in Genesis 3:22, "Then the Lord
God said, 'Behold, the man has become
like one of us to know good and evil.
And now, lest he put out his hand and
take also of the tree of life and eat
and live forever.'"
God said, "Not a good idea. Not safe
right now."
So,
you know, as much as we want to, as much
as we try to create methods to do that,
I don't think God would allow it. Yes,
Keith, you're right. I also think the
devil is trying to create a situation
where it's like he's made it, it's his
thing. So, are they subject to the same
rules and laws that got us and do they
need salvation? You know, like like he's
trying to find a way to be saved and to
offer that to other people outside of
God. I think that's what you really
you're really getting at this at the at
the heart of like even these
philosophies and stuff like this. I
mean, they're they're literally talking
about salvation. Yes, yes, because if
you create these kind of machines or if
you improve yourself
to this level in which you don't need
anything else. So, what is the role of
God? You don't need God.
Right. If you can make yourself live
forever, But it's it's not human anymore
at that point. You know, you look at how
the Bible defines
life, it's body
plus
you know,
breath of God equals living soul.
Remove the body.
Yeah. Oh, that's actually a really
interesting question.
Right? Cuz it's a spiritual event. It's
not just a mechanical event. Right. God
made us in his image.
Yeah. And we as humans have been very
good at tainting that image of God in
various ways, including Yeah. you know,
just completely demolishing the body
that we have, which is a temple of the
Holy Spirit. And um yeah, I I I see your
point. Mhm. Yeah. And you know, just to
throw one more thing out there. I think
that
the the interesting thing when you kind
of really hear them talking about
they've made movies about this. I think
there was one called surrogates, which
basically they made robots and you
could, you know, live your life out
through this robot. The morality,
there's no morality.
If there's no consequence for the
morality
and it's just like, you know, you're
just there to seek pleasure. I think
anytime that humanity takes out of the
equation of God, it's like we will
default to
the biggest pursuit of pleasure. That's
all that we're going to try to do is
just how I'm
I I just don't think that that that
they're saying download your
consciousness and you're never going to
feel anything again.
Yeah, I mean, if there were no
consequences for your actions, what
would you be like? What would you do?
Yeah, it's it's a interesting
philosophical question and I think these
guys are are not necessarily dress
addressing that, but they're they are in
the movies of saying like, "Do you have
you ever wanted to do whatever you want
to do and be a prostitute and have no
consequences of that?" You know, it's
like here you can live it out like this.
And I think that's that's that's what
the devil's always been trying to do is
have no consequences for his actions.
We see Yeah, we see all of this. I mean,
there's even early fluttering stages of
this. I was just looking at how
um OpenAI, the company behind ChatGPT,
is looking at making
responsible
porn.
As if that exists.
Yeah. Yeah, that's an oxymoron.
well, how do you do that? Well, what was
really telling in in the article, I
think it's by Wired,
was, you know, they want to they want to
do things that are safe and beneficial.
That's part of their mission statement.
But
but how do you make not safe for work
content that's safe and beneficial is is
one question.
And another question was
um
they or another statement that one of
their one of their people that work for
OpenAI was saying
um
you we want to meet societal
expectations.
I was like, well,
what if society changes?
You know, what if society decides
tomorrow
murder is completely okay?
So, then we shouldn't make OpenAI be
like, "How do I murder somebody?" you
know?
Those are the kinds of questions that
that come into ethical space,
you know, when we are driven by a
whatever society wants viewpoint,
relativism. I think this is a matter of
the technology can be great and help you
with things, but where's the morality
fit into this? Yeah.
You know, the Bible is absolute
in terms of truth. Mhm. Zero or one.
Right. Right. No points in between.
But, you know, truth nowadays
in our culture is very relativistic.
You know, you have your truth, you have
your truth, I have my truth. That's
fine.
What if I use
ChatGPT, for example,
to make these moral decisions?
You know, to to tell me to help me take
these moral decisions.
So, who is behind, you know, or which
data was used to
to help people, you know, to make these?
So,
it's delicate. Well, it's it's it's even
even beyond that. It's it's not just
moral decisions. Like, I wouldn't
and I'm not condemning anybody that
does, but I wouldn't use it to
do sermon prep work for me.
I don't I don't think that's
right. And the reason I don't think it's
right is because the Bible says
spiritual things are spiritually
discerned.
It's not a spiritual being.
Of course. So, there's no possibility
that it can ever do that. It might be
able to scan the text, read the text,
and tell you these historical things
happened or these facts happened. But to
produce a spiritual thought,
I don't think it's capable of that. I
agree with you. Cuz it's not made in the
image of God like we are.
And if it's pulling from all kinds of
data sets, that's what these things do,
right? Then it's pulling from every
religion or anything that somebody's
commented on this thing, what's the
parameters of that? The Wall Street
Journal actually ran an article where
they were exploring the idea of using AI
to guide people spiritually based on
your belief system.
So, you're like, I guess you would tell
it, "I'm Jewish. Now, here's my, you
know, ethical dilemma or question. So,
what should I do based on the fact that
I'm
Jewish?" Well, that's fascinating. Well,
it's not based on one truth. It's again
your own truth. I I I think more so than
putting it together though,
a use of searchability. Like, show me
all the texts that deal with this.
That's the use of AI.
No problem. That's useful. Yeah. But
yeah, and we should use it, you know,
in fact, at college,
I tell my students, let's use artificial
intelligence in the right way.
You know, so you have this biblical
framework, you know, that supports all
these new trends that you are using.
Let's use it, you know, because the
Bible is going to tell you how to use
it, in which situations, and which for
which ones would you you should not use
them.
Let me show you something else. This is
from Kurzweil.
This is a
from a book called
The Singularity Is Near, okay?
This is powerful, a powerful quote,
okay? So remember Ray Kurzweil is a big
figure, you know, in terms of science,
computer science, and you know, he's
he's well known. So the merging is the
essence of the singularity. Merging,
okay? An era in which our intelligence
will become increasingly non-biological
and trillions of times more powerful
than it is today. So merging is about,
you know, merging our
Yeah, man and machine, okay?
Transhumanism, the dawning of a new
civilization. And this is beautiful, you
know, when you read it, you say, "Wow,
this is
so cool." The dawning of a new
civilization that will enable us to
transcend our biological limitations and
amplify our creativity.
So far so good. Yeah.
We will be able to assume different
bodies. Oh boy, you know, different
bodies.
And take on a range of persona
at will.
In practical terms, human aging and
illness will be reversed.
Sounds cool. And will ultimately turn
even death into a soluble problem.
So I have highlighted this, different
bodies
or different personas
persona
and turn even death into a soluble
problem.
Different personas like
you could change whether you were male,
female, or otherwise,
or prostitute, or you know, it's all
pain. Yeah, sports player or actor.
Yeah, you take roles, you know, you take
different roles. So you're
schizophrenic. I was about to say how
does this this not just completely cause
mental disorders?
So it has implications related to reach
immortality through machines as we have
mentioned, okay? By our own means. So in
the Bible we find in Genesis chapter 3
verses 4 4 and 5,
you know, the serpent, the devil, Satan,
said to the woman, "You will not surely
die.
For God knows that in the day you eat of
it, your eyes will be opened
and you will be like God,
knowing good and evil, knowing knowing
everything." The ancient story. The
ancient story.
Once again, this is the devil trying to
figure out how to to basically God
cannot lie. So if God tells you that
that you are going to die and the devil
keeps trying, he's tried for 6,000 years
and he's just he's just going to go back
to God and be like, "See, you didn't let
me try. You didn't let me try it my way.
You said that they would die, but I came
up with a solution for them not to die
and you're not letting me do that." I
mean, that's
You know that that verse I was alluding
to in in Genesis earlier from Genesis
3:22, how God had removed the ability
for them to have access to the tree of
life, so they couldn't live forever
because of sin, right?
Cuz if you can live forever and there's
no and it's just continued sinfulness,
then there's no consequence. Sin never
ends, right? It just keeps continues to
perpetuate evil. And so far we've just
seen pain and suffering and death as a
result of that.
You go all the way forward to
Revelation,
it says, "Blessed are those who do his
commandments that they may have right to
the tree of life and enter through the
gates of the city."
You look at the Ten Commandments and
it's like here are 10 principles that
God builds morality out of. This is the
basis of
at least in Christianity and and Judaism
ethics and and morals.
That's conditional on you living
forever. Right.
Immortality
is literally only given by God.
And it's for doing Yeah, it's for doing
what you're doing. And look at what the
consequence is of sin. It's just You
don't get immortality. It's
that simple.
Eternal death and we see it also
here in Ezekiel 18:4, "The soul who sins
shall die." You know,
in Romans, "For the wages of sin is
death, but the gift of God is eternal."
So it is a gift from God.
So the idea of assuming different bodies
because we also saw that, you know,
from this quote from Kurzweil.
So
this is transhumanism goes in hand with
the idea of the error of immortality of
the soul.
And according to this great book, I
recommend this book to each one of you
in the audience, The Great Controversy
from Ellen G. White. This is a great
book.
Ellen G. White mentions that through
which through this error of immortality
of the soul,
Satan will bring the people under his
deceptions in the last day before the
second coming of Christ by laying the
foundation of spiritualism. So we are
talking about spiritualism here. This is
not just about technology.
So you see something great, something
beautiful, you know, artificial
intelligence is great,
but with these implications related to
spiritualism. That quote that you
brought before where it basically was
saying that you know, you can blend the
human body with the technology. I cannot
help but to think of the statue of
Daniel. Each one of these civilizations
had these like you know, different
things. The head of gold is Babylon, you
know, Greece, Media-Persia, all those.
All the way down to the feet that's a
mixture of clay and iron. And
you know, I can't help to think the
Bible talks about clay being, you know,
we are the clay, God's molding us,
right? And iron is usually typical
man-made, right? I just don't think God
would ever let us blend his creation
with something that we have literally
made in this way. And I understand, yes,
a pacemaker,
we have been sort of implementing
technology inside of us, so that I hear
these arguments. But I still think like
I don't think God would let this happen.
Yeah, that's a good point, great point.
I don't think
I know. I I I just I think that we're at
the seriously Jesus is at the door. So
I'm guessing you're not getting a
microchip.
No, sorry. I'm going to I'm going to be
I'm going to be a second and third
class. I just hope I'm a seventh class
citizen, you know.
That is a great point, you know, in the
future.
Here I have a slide, let me go Okay, I I
will wait for that slide.
But what will happen if we become second
class citizens if we are not
transhumans?
As slaves.
Yes, maybe.
Take a look at this from Preparation for
the End Time from Pacific Press
Publishing Association. As long as
anyone believes that at at death the
soul goes on living in one form or
another.
That person is wide open to most occult
or spiritualistic deceptions.
Deceptions that can easily promote the
idea either openly or by implication
that you don't need Jesus for salvation.
That is
very interesting.
Take a look at this. This is a very
well-known book, Homo Deus from Yuval
Noah Harari, a well-known book, a
best-seller.
Take a look at this. Technohumanism
agrees that Homo sapiens as we know it
has run its historical course and will
not longer be relevant in the future,
but concludes that we should therefore
use technology in order to create Homo
Deus,
a much superior human model.
So you see? Yeah, the next level for
humans.
You know, the model just keeps going
until you remove humanity.
Because the the idea beyond Homo Deus is
Deus ex machina.
You know, God from the machine. So this
is Homo is man-god? Yeah.
Yes. Yes. Homo Deus will retain some
essential human features, but will also
enjoy upgraded physical and mental
abilities. And then you see again these
nice words.
They sound very nice, you know,
but take a look at the
spiritual implications of this. Where
does it end? Like at what point does it
no longer become humanity
as part of this amalgamation of man and
machine? That's what we saw earlier,
right? There was a quote that was
talking about that that AI will
basically destroy humanity.
So that would be the end of that. People
are afraid of that.
That's a good question. Since we don't
know the future, we know the future that
the Bible says. We know that that
future.
But you know, these are ideas,
you know, and people, you know,
so many people believe this and follow
this. So
I prepared this slide to show you the
new way of
seeing evolution, okay? So evolution is
not just about looking at the past, you
know, some people talk about the Big
Bang and you know, evolutionists
related processes,
but now we have to think about the
future, you know, this combination of
technology and hum- and humans to come
into Homodeus. Homodeus, the next step
of evolution. So, and as you mentioned,
yeah, about the Babel Tower,
this is a way of avoiding the course of
mortality through machines. Okay?
In my opinion,
it is sacrilegious and self-centered,
you know, to say, you know, I can avoid
death by my own means. I don't need God.
It is to upgrade us and our creations to
the level of God, Homodeus.
Can you imagine that? Yeah, the Tower of
Babel really was less about building
something that you could just never
flood, you know, it was more about what
that stood for.
Um
I mean, honestly, you you're you're
never going to outsmart God if he wants
to like destroy the thing, right? And
and it's the mentality that this was
going to perpetuate that you don't need
God. Yeah, that's what was the danger of
the Tower of Babel. Correct. Correct.
So, here we have this quote from Isaiah
chapter 14. Homodeus is an attempt to
occupy the place of God. Okay? This is
about Satan, you know, or Lucifer at
that time, you know, before
committing this this this sin, "How you
are falling from heaven, O Lucifer, son
of the morning, how you are cut down to
the ground, you who weaken the nations.
For you have said in your heart" Take a
look at this. "I will ascend into
heaven, Homodeus." Mhm.
"I will exalt my throne above the stars
of God. I will also sit on the mount of
of the congregation on the farthest side
of the north. I will ascend." You see,
ascend, ascend, ascend above the heights
of the clouds, I will be like the most
high. My intelligence will get to such a
superintelligence.
Ultra-intelligence, you know, an
explosion of intelligence.
Second component, superior machines as
the new idols. Okay? Superior machines
are the new idols.
This is from uh Penrose.
Uh he published this book in 1994
in Oxford University Press.
Uh this is from a well-known book. So,
if we accept the that computers and
computer-guided robots will eventually,
and even perhaps before too long, exceed
all human capabilities, then the
computers will be able to do
immeasurably more than merely assist our
intelligences, which is something that
we see nowadays. You see Siri and so on.
They will actually have immense
intelligences of their own. We could
then turn to this superior intelligence
for advice and authority in all matters.
Mhm. Yeah. In all matters of concern and
the humanity-induced troubles of the
world could at last be resolved. So, in
other words,
we are not able, you know, as humans
version 1.0 to solve
all these problems, you know, as Homo
sapiens as Yuval Noah Noah Harari
mentions.
So, we need something better to solve
all these matters, problems in humanity.
So,
when I read this,
I think that this is connected to
uh idols.
Yeah, we're making our own God. Yes. So,
if you have a problem, are you going to
go to God? No. Yeah. You go to the
artificial intelligence Yeah. that is
going to tell you, "Ah, do this, do
that." You know, we just talked about
morality. Even in in terms of morality,
you will ask them Yeah. what to do.
Yeah. I I know it's weird, but but do
you think it's just
a an Apple computer with a bite taken
out of it? I know it means knowledge. I
know it means knowledge. But don't you
think it's very eerie that that is the
symbol of like one of the top
technological companies in the world?
You know what I mean? Not to say that
you can't use an Apple computer, but I
just think it's a very interesting They
are connections, yes, Cody. They are
connections. Mhm. Uh that's why it's
important to have a strong biblical
worldview. Yeah.
To to understand
how this reality, you know, is
connecting to each other.
And that according to the prophecy,
according to the Bible, we'll know what
to do. Mhm. Yeah. We need this strong
ground. Mhm.
Third implication of the singularity, a
faulty imitation of conscience in
machines. So, conscience is the part of
the mind that makes you aware of your
actions as being either morally right or
wrong. Okay? Right or wrong.
So, I I read this article some years ago
in the MIT Technology Review from MIT.
It is entitled, "Can You Make Artificial
Intelligence Fairer Than a Judge?"
So, play our courtroom courtroom
algorithm game. So, there is a system
used here in the United States called
Compas
that is currently being used to realize
who has to go to jail and who can be at
home while waiting for a trial. Okay?
So,
decisions that are being taken based on
the algorithm. And this is a black box.
And what they demonstrated in this
article is that this Compas system
is unfair.
Yeah. It's unfair. Unfair. Interesting.
Yeah. Yeah, and they they they quote in
this article from the MIT
this or the other article from
ProPublica.
Uh
take a look at this example. So, here we
have two petty uh theft arrests, okay,
from these two people. Wow. So, you can
see that this person was uh White guy.
classified low low three and this person
as eight. And you can see that the
things that this guy did were big, you
know, bigger than the things that this
person did. These are bad things, of
course. Wow. But
So, what kind of serious data was it
fed? Was it only fed court data or was
it fed images of people? Was it fed
demographics?
It's a black box. And the reason I ask
is because AI is only going to be as
good as what it's trained on.
And when it comes to court data, it
would be trained on
what we've done as a society. It So, if
we were biased, for example, it would be
biased.
It would be biased. Yeah.
Yes, of course. For example, you are a
nice person, but you live in a bad
neighborhood. So, you will have a higher
risk, you know, because of your
neighborhood. Mhm. Yeah. And this is
like some Minority Report stuff. Do you
remember that movie that came out? Like
they they had the computers that were
choosing whether or not you were going
to commit a crime or not.
Based on what you would do in the
future. Yes. Yes. And nowadays also, if
you want to, you know, you go to the
bank to ask money for to buy a house,
you know,
these are algorithms that make the
decision. How do they take the decision?
How, you know? And this is a black box.
You cannot ask him which data they are
using.
Yeah. They will not tell you that. Yeah.
So, take a look at this other example.
Uh high risk 10 for these offenses that
are not as big as these other ones. Wow.
So,
this is a very interesting article. I
recommend this
and they have a game, you know? You can
play with different variable values and
so on and you can realize that, yeah,
this system, you know, the legal system
has this problem, you know? Mhm. So,
this is the problem of garbage in,
garbage out.
Mhm. Yeah, if you feed these kind of
programs, you know, models with wrong
data, you will get garbage, you know,
which is negative for the society. Mhm.
And the final
implication is consciousness is a spirit
in a spiritual machines. Okay?
Consciousness. So, consciousness,
it is the condition of being conscious.
So, right now we are conscious. Yeah, we
know that we are here.
We are talking about this topic. We
Okay.
We will know about this reality. This is
the normal state of being awake and able
to understand what is happening around
you.
So,
it is about the five senses, the reason
and ability of the mind, imagination,
and emotion,
and memory. And these are mysteries for
us. We don't know
how or why we dream
or even when suddenly we have these
ideas, you know, like these explosive
ideas. Why? Mhm. Where does it come
from? Yes, we don't know. These are
mysteries, you know, chemical reactions
that happen in our brains, but we don't
know. In fact,
from the examples that I showed you at
the beginning about deep learning and so
on, artificial neural networks,
so, we just know the basics of
artificial neural networks.
Mhm. We know that they are neurons
connected to other neurons and we try
try to imitate these in machines,
but we don't know more than that. Yeah.
We don't know that. So,
now, let's connect this idea of
consciousness to these quotes from these
two books, Life 3.0, Being Human in the
Age of Artificial Intelligence and The
Singularity, A Philosophical Analysis.
So,
in this quote, "The rise of artificial
intelligence adds a sudden urgency to
the study of consciousness because if we
really want to create
full general artificial intelligence,
strong artificial intelligence, we need
to understand consciousness. Mhm.
Otherwise,
we will have like these intelligent
parrots, just like ChatGPT. Mhm. Which I
think is mostly what it is, right?
Yes, it's an intelligent parrot. Yeah.
Specifically to the question of
predicting which intelligent entities
has have subjective experiences.
As the experiences that we have as
humans, which so many of them are
subjective. And in this other quote,
"Nevertheless, having a subjective
experience is a hard problem, a
mystery." Mhm. It's a mystery. Mhm. We
don't know
it works.
Mhm. So, how can we imitate
consciousness in machines? Mhm. And now
let's connect this idea to what Ray
Kurzweil says in his book, The
Singularity Is Near.
He says that when the singularity
arrives, the cosmos will wake up and be
conscious.
So, in other words, we will have
artificial intelligences that are
conscious, that have this consciousness
and will be sublimely intelligent. Okay?
Everything is evolving toward infinite
infinite beauty and creativity and love.
So, you see, there is
Mhm.
this um
maybe impossibility or difficulty of
understanding subjective experiences and
consciousness. I find it really
interesting what you're saying here that
it says um sublimely intelligent.
Everything is evolving toward infinite
beauty, infinite creativity, infinite
love. That's how God made us before the
fall. Mhm. Right? And we were supposed
to live forever Mhm. with this infinite
beauty and creativity and love and etc.
Mhm. And we've been on the decline as as
a humanity for about 6,000 years.
Mhm. I mean, I cannot like we look now
at like the most beautiful people in the
world. I mean, they're going to be
unattractive compared to Adam and Eve
when we see them.
Mhm. Satan's selling you a pipe dream.
Exactly. But then like
this is basically trying to point us
back to the Garden of Eden but a
counterfeit.
Mhm.
An artificial intelligence kind of uh
Garden of Eden experience or actually
when we look forward an artificial
intelligence experience of heaven what
God is going to promise us. He's having
a whole counterfeit to point point you
in the wrong direction. He's looking for
the fountain of youth. Yeah. Jesus is
the fountain of youth. Yeah.
Like, you know what I mean? Like,
they're selling you this idea, live
forever and drink this thing stir and
you know you know do this and it's like
but but that's what was already offered
over here, you know?
Yeah. The problem is
so many people don't understand the
character of God. Mhm. And and because
they see God a certain way
then they're like, well, if that's what
I have to do to get eternal life
Mhm.
I'll look for a different way. You mean
I got to sell my stuff and help my
neighbor out? What? And I'm thinking too
of Roger Morneau,
former Satanist, passed away now, but he
was he was a Satanist, part of a
Satanist cult.
Pretty high up, left and became a
Christian.
And did an interview and there's a this
interview is like 3 hours long and in he
talks about that he heard from the high
priest of Satanism that
these people, the Satanists, believe
that Jesus is going to give the planet
back to Satan.
Right? That Jesus is eventually going to
say, well, Satan was actually the
rightful owner all along and here you
go, you just live forever here and then
he and so Roger Morneau says, that's why
so many of these celebrities and people
are involved in this cult and this
satanic stuff because
they believe this and they're like,
well, we're worship Satan because we can
live with that do what thou wilt shall
be the whole of the law. Do whatever you
want forever because Satan is actually
our king and our prince of this world,
right? And and this is the same thing,
the same principle like, don't look to
God, I've got a counterfeit for you
here, but you can do whatever you want
forever.
And you can also see that uh there are
technical impossibilities of
achieving this, you know, understanding
consciousness. But this philosophical
movement of the singularity is saying,
yes, it's possible.
So
You have to go with God's a liar if this
is possible. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And it is
interesting that Kurzweil, he knows
about science.
But
he's talking about things that
scientific scientifically speaking are
impossible or very very difficult to
achieve. And then he's just, you know,
happily saying, yeah, it's possible to
be conscious or to achieve this
consciousness in machines.
So
in science you have to be very careful,
yeah, about what's possible, what's not
possible.
But okay. Well, apparently you can you
can take a bunch of elements and toss
them all together and and immediately it
will somehow create life. Yes. Yes. I I
I Maybe That's an impossibility. And the
point is with these kind of words is to
try to convince as many people as
possible, you know, to follow this
trend. To follow this trend, yeah.
Uh
this is the the cover of the book, The
Age of Spiritual Machines. The Age of
Spiritual Machines also by Kurzweil.
Uh
and his objective is to create these
conscious machines, you know? He's what
what he's he's saying in this book and
to create machines with life or with a
soul towards a conscious cosmos, The Age
of Spiritual Machines.
So, as you mentioned, according to the
Bible we have this equation. A living
human being is body dust plus breath
from God, spirit, equals a living soul.
Mhm. So, from what Kurzweil and other
people are saying, you know,
uh let's remove some of these components
and at the end you you are a living
soul, you know, in a different body.
But you are a living soul. Right. So, if
you do the equation, we are a living
soul, is what the Bible says as a human
being.
Yeah, according to this equation. Yeah.
So, if you take away the breath of God,
which is literally what he breathed into
his nostrils in Genesis when gave us
life we have a dead body, right?
Mhm. But it's a but then it's the same
thing here as as you said
you might take away the body
and you die as well. It's the same
concept.
Mhm. Mhm.
So, in conclusion uh
human beings were created in the image
of God. Mhm. And it makes us so
especial.
So, we're especial because of creation
the image of God or imago Dei
and we are especial also because of
redemption.
God died for you, for each one of us.
Mhm. It makes us
very extremely especial. Mhm. He became
one of us and he became human. Yes, this
is so deep. I I I invite all of you, you
have the time, hopefully yes, to read
the book of John. Mhm. The piece of you
know, the the book, the the the gospel
of John.
To read it, you know, it is it is so
deep. Mhm. Read try to go deeper into
the words of Jesus in this book. And you
will find all this love, profound love
from God, you know, who came, who
materialized as a human Mhm.
for you. Mhm. For each one of of us. So,
we are also spiritual.
A machine is not a spiritual, you know,
Kurzweil say, The Age of Spiritual
Machines, but machines are not a
spiritual.
Machines can imitate
some things, you know? A machine can
tell you, I love you. Mhm. But you know,
you can have an avatar telling you, you
know, I love you, but you know, that
this is just a model thing saying that.
Mhm. So, we are also intellectual,
creative, social, affective, sexual.
God has given us the freedom of choice.
Mhm.
These machines don't do not have freedom
of choice. Mhm.
God has made us creatures creatures,
sorry, with the capacity to love and
hate. Mhm. Emotions. A machine doesn't
have emotions. Yeah. Uh
if you have the time, uh please go to
the Bible and read these Bible verses.
Mhm. These are quite quite deep. God has
sent his son to restore us to his image.
Mhm. And on the day of judgment, and
this is important, Scotty, God will hold
us accountable for our decisions. Mhm.
So, you see when you see the world, the
reality through this biblical
perspective you know that in the future
there is a judgment. Mhm. And every
action Mhm. has an effect, you know?
There is something, you know?
Mhm. That that that we that can happen
in this day of judgment. So,
we need to be prepared. Mhm. We need to
be prepared. So,
um
this is my last slide. Contrary to the
idea of the singularity and
transhumanism, humans are unique
and have the privilege of being created
in the image of God, imago Dei. Mhm. And
I would like to read this uh from Psalms
uh 139:14. I will praise you for I am
fearfully and wonderfully made,
especial. Marvelous are your works and
that my soul knows very well. Amen.
Amen.
I think it's a powerful thought that you
ended with it you know, here we are, we
we essentially by sin
destroyed God's image. Yep. In in, you
know, what he started with he created.
But then the beauty is God said, I can
fix that. Yes. You know, I can restore
that image.
And we have the opportunity to to take
part in that and instead of trying to do
it in our own strength and in our own
way through technological means or
artificial means if we would just take
God's invitation and let him do his work
in us, it would be so much better.
Amen. Good thoughts. Harvey, what a
blessing that you have brought to us. I
know this topic is probably way grander
than what we could probably handle in an
hour. But
you know, do you have a a YouTube
channel or website that that uh we can
send people to?
I have here my contact information. All
right. Here you can see my website.
There you can see my publications
or
on Twitter. I like to use Twitter or X,
you know, to share
Bible verses or things that I find on
science and so on. And this is my email.
Yes.
if Yes, Harvey has a lot of great
information a lot of great information.
If you have questions, I'm sure he'd
welcome those questions and you're
welcome to email him or you can put it
in the in the chat below and we will try
to answer everything that comes. Most of
the things we try to get to, but um
I hope you guys were blessed today and I
hope the one thing that you heard out of
this conversation is really that God
loves us with an immense love and that
he wants to save us and there is no
salvation outside of a relationship with
Jesus. So, you know, don't get
distracted by all this technology and
and and wowed by how amazing this seems.
You know, I think in eternity you're
going to see that if you put your faith
and trust in God, it will by far
outweigh anything that this technology
can do for us today.
Um thank you guys for listening. We have
a lot of cool merch. Go to
lightwear.shop. You can get the image of
God He has it right
He's wearing it on his chest right now
and um there's a lot of things that you
guys can do as well. Just give this this
video a little thumbs up. Share it with
somebody that you think would like it.
That's a simple way you can actually
help support us and if you'd like to
support our ministry and help us
continue to to produce videos like this,
then you're welcome to go to
littlelightstudios.tv
donate and you can help our ministry
produce more of this content. And check
out @biblescripturesongs
on YouTube for AI scripture songs where
AI is used positively. That's right. You
can see we got a lot of stuff going on
here, but we have one more thing. Little
Light Kids, tell us about that, Deniece.
Yes, so if you want to see some uh cool
creative videos for your kids that are
safe to watch, check out
littlelightkids.com
for like a Netflix-style uh website for
kids content safe kids content or go to
littlelightkids on YouTube and
subscribe.
We thank you guys for stopping by. We'll
see you next week. Yep.
Finally, my brethren,
be strong in the Lord and in
all his might.
Put on the full
armor of God
that you may be able to stand against
the wiles of the devil.
Therefore, take up the whole
armor of God
that you may be able to stand
against the wiles of the devil.